Now that we've launched the Twinmotion from the Epic Games launcher, or however you launched it,
we're going to take a look at some of the templates that are available to us before moving forward and starting in the project.
So you'll notice there are actually 11 different templates, originally at 8.
So we've expanded a few since the original release and
so some of those as you can see our new ones are the LED wall for virtual production and we have a few of
the originals that are
updated such as the Iceland, the Beach, Desert, and Salt Flats.
So when you get a chance, feel free to explore it.
But for today's purposes, we're just going to take a look at those and move right into an actual project.
Now there's also another project included which we'll take a look at later, but let's move forward.